[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
[Music]
the three body problem series aka the
remembrance of earth's past trilogy is
one of the coolest modern science
fiction series that i've read
reading about humanity's struggle
throughout the eons to survive in a
hostile cosmos is beyond compelling to
me in this video i'll pick up where i
left off in the last video at the
beginning of the deterrence era which
brought peace between the tricelerians
and humanity keep in mind that this
video will have spoilers for the books
part one the sword holders
the doomsday battle was the bloodiest
single event in history up until that
point
tricelerian technology had proven to be
far beyond the scope of what humans had
actually prepared for
in a ridiculously short period of time
all of humanity's space force had been
annihilated
a few ships survived to await some
lonely and cold existence out in deep
space
the people of earth were left in shock
and horror as even more tricelerian
probes with greater destructive power
than humans had previously even
conceived of speed tore at the earth
they were saved by the actions of the
wall facer lulu g
who became the world's first ever sword
holder i go into detail as to how this
happened in this video if you haven't
seen it i highly recommend you watch it
before this one in it i explain the
concepts of chain of suspicion and
deterrence game theory which are key to
understanding the events of the series
as they play out from this point on
essentially lulu g held the tricelerians
at bay by threat of mutually assured
destruction
if the tricelerian showed aggression
towards humanity he would activate a
detonator which would reveal the
location of trisolaris and the earth to
the greater universe
based on the logic of dark forest
hypothesis which we've covered in detail
in other videos in this series this
would mean death for both worlds as some
hunter in the dark forest was bound to
notice the worlds and act to destroy
them the trisolarens and humanity had
both determined independently of each
other that luogi's likelihood of
fulfilling the threat should the
tricelerance violate deterrence was well
over ninety percent but everyone knew
luogi could not live forever eventually
a new sword holder would have to be
chosen in the third book in the series
we meet the woman who would eventually
become the world's second ever sword
holder
and the last
it was decided that a vote would be held
to elect the next sword holder
xiangzin had been one of seven
candidates the other six were all men
the election took place about 60 years
into the deterrence era
i should acknowledge that this
particular section of the book presents
some pretty questionable ideas about the
nature of masculinity and femininity
this may be where some of the authors
real world beliefs seep into the
narrative i just thought i'd point this
out as some readers may definitely be
off put by it
shangzin was the favorite candidate for
a few reasons one she had served in the
pia aka the pdc strategic intelligence
agency which in the last few centuries
had actively gathered an enormous amount
of intelligence about trisolaris
they had even warned of the imminent
droplet attack but were not listened to
by this point in history the pia
possessed an almost legendary status in
the public's view
also the public had grown to think
differently about the tricelerians yet
again
in fact tricelerians had begun to make a
significant impact on human culture and
art
the art and culture of this age were
nothing like she had imagined but it
wasn't simply a matter of a return to
classical style either
it was more of a spiraling sublimation
of post-postmodernism
built upon a new aesthetic foundation
for instance a fairy tale of youngstee
contained profound metaphors for the
universe and space-time but xiangzin was
most impressed by the disappearance of
the gloomy despair and bizarre noise so
prevalent in the post-modern culture and
art of the 21st century in their place
was an unprecedented warm serenity and
optimism
i love your era
said changzin i'm surprised
you'd be even more surprised if you knew
the artist behind these films paintings
and music
they're all trisallerans from four light
years away a.a laughed uproariously as
she observed chongxing's stunned gate
essentially humanity began to see the
tricelerins as more like them
some began to believe that perhaps the
tricelerins wouldn't carry out an attack
even if the sword holder failed to carry
out the deterrence threat
perhaps the symbol of the sword holder
was all that mattered
also the tricelerins have created a sort
of emissary on earth an android she is
the voice of trisolaris on this world
the tricelerians instead of continuing
the trend of silence have now elected to
speak through this form she is referred
to as simply sophon
the android takes the form of a gentle
japanese woman
she appears harmless a far cry from the
cold intangible form sophon had
previously taken the tricelerians had
even helped with the development of
human science giving humanity supposedly
crucial details about the nature of the
cosmos opinions of the tricelerians
gradually shifted
essentially this exposes the very
short-term memory of humanity
when humans are comfortable they begin
to take that comfort for granted they
assume that it will continue to exist
they forget about the mistakes of the
past and the forgotten past is often
repeated
if shangzin was chosen she would have to
attack fast if the tricelerans went on
the offensive she would have to make the
decision to destroy her own world in
that moment with no time to ponder
humanity was not so naive as to believe
that the tricelerians had turned the
other droplet probes away from the solar
system
it was likely that they were hidden
somewhere within the solar system
invisible from detection
even by spreading oil films or using
other advanced detection techniques
humans could only reliably detect
droplets if they approach within one
tenth of an au of earth
or 15 million kilometers outside the
sphere the droplets were free to roam
undetected at maximum speed a droplet
could cross 15 million kilometers in 10
minutes this is all the time the sword
holder would have to make a decision if
dark force deterrence broke down
ultimately shangzin is elected as sword
holder and the transference process
between her and liu ji is complete
shangzi knows that from this day forward
she and the detonator will be one it
would almost be like a part of her body
she looked at the red switch in her hand
it was already a part of her
she and it would be inseparable from now
on
even when she slept she had to keep it
by her pillow
the white semi-circular hall was deathly
silent as though time was sealed in here
and no longer flowed it really did
resemble a tomb
but this would be her entire world from
now on she decided that she had to give
life to this place
she didn't want to be like luji
she wasn't a warrior a duelist she was a
woman and she needed to live here for a
long time perhaps a decade perhaps half
a century
indeed she had been preparing for this
mission her whole life
now that she stood at the starting point
of her long journey she felt calm
in xiangzin's mind she was a protector
not a destroyer not a warrior she was
willing to use the remaining years of
her life to maintain the balance between
the world of trisolyris and the earth
before she accepted the sword holder
role she had a conversation with the
android sophon who tells her that it is
both of their duties to make the earth
beautiful and prosperous
shangzin believed the earth would grow
stronger with tricelerian science and at
the same time trisolaris would grow more
civilized with earth culture
one day she hoped the world would no
longer need a sword holder
put down that red switch and return to
the surface
the world no longer needs dark forest
deterrence no longer needs a sword
holder
as i stated in my deterrence error video
deterrence works because of the
guarantee of mutually assured
destruction
luigi's likelihood of fulfilling the
threat was something that the
tricelerians could determine
mathematically
so it stands to reason that it was also
something that they could determine
about xiangzin
it took 15 minutes after the transfer of
the sword holder position for the
tricelerins to violate deterrence the
resulting devastation was macroscopic in
comparison to the devastation of the
first droplet attack
when she faced that distant world as the
sword holder xiangzin unlike luoji did
not feel this was a life or death
contest
she thought of it as a game of chess
she would sit tranquilly before the
chessboard
thinking of all the openings
anticipating the opponent's attacks and
devising her own responses she was ready
to spend her life playing this game
but her opponents hadn't bothered to
move any pieces on the board
instead they had simply lifted the
chessboard and smashed it at her head
part two
the invasion
the tri-salarians attacked the stations
on earth which would activate the spell
revealing the locations of both worlds
during this time xiangzin can only watch
frozen in horror
she had known deep down that she could
never carry out the threat
but she had been convinced that she
would not have to it was a mistake that
would affect every human on earth
the red light on the screen faded
replaced by the white background from
before
the room seemed brighter and more open a
few lines of black text appeared
north american gravitational wave
transmitter destroyed
european gravitational wave transmitter
destroyed
asian gravitational wave transmitter
destroyed
solar radio application function
suppressed on all bands
silence once again reigned over
everything
except the faint sound of water
trickling somewhere a pipe had burst
during the quake xiang zhin understood
that the droplet attack on the asian
gravitational wave transmitter had
caused the earthquake the antenna was
about 20 kilometers from here
and was also deeply buried
the droplets had not even bothered
attacking the sword holder
the black text disappeared after some
moments of blankness a last screen of
text faded in
gravitational wave universal broadcast
system cannot be recovered dark forest
deterrence has been terminated
the tricelerians had known that xiangzin
would not act
they had done everything they could to
manipulate her into accepting the
position and had done everything they
could so that humanity would accept her
as their sword holder
after all these years the tricelerians
had learned deception
this was due to the fact that they had
been given access to a human brain
but we will discuss how that happened in
another video
as it is extremely relevant to events
later in the books
initially the tricelerians had no way to
directly study a human brain but
suddenly they did
in a speech broadcasted to the entire
planet the sofon android finally reveals
its true nature and admits that they had
only been waiting for humanity to let
down its guard
waiting for them to become weak
they had given them false science and
never had any intention of actually
helping humanity
sophon became the herald of the second
trisolaren invasion
sophon reveals that the second
tricelerian fleet would arrive in
approximately four years to complete the
conquest of the solar system
the trisolarens claimed to no longer
intend to exterminate the human race but
instead they would allow them to live on
reservations throughout the solar system
most humans would migrate to the island
of australia
somehow however even with the fall of
deterrence humanity hadn't fully
accepted its fate
they made no move to surrender holding
to the illusion that they may have one
final tranquil generation
they were wrong
after sofon's speech no country
responded and no one actually immigrated
five days after this historical
reservation proclamation
one of the five droplets cruising within
the earth's atmosphere attacked three
large cities in asia europe and north
america the purpose of the attacks
wasn't to destroy the cities but to
instill terror
the droplet passed straight through the
giant forest of these cities colliding
with all hanging buildings that happened
to be in the way the struck buildings
burned and then fell several hundred
meters like over ripe fruits
over three hundred thousand people died
in the worst disaster since the doomsday
battle
people finally understood that to the
droplets the human world was as fragile
as eggs under a poised rock
cities and large-scale facilities were
defenseless
if the tricelerans wanted they could lay
waste to every city until the surface of
the earth was one large ruin
i would say that a brutal war was waged
between humanity and the tricelerians
but it was not a war it was a slaughter
humanity was no match for the might of
the tricelerians the tricelerins forced
humanity out of every corner of the
earth and crowded most of them into
australia
anyone that resisted was quite simply
annihilated to the tricelerians
humankind were bugs insignificant
creatures that either must comply or be
eliminated
they intended to let the remnants of
humanity exist in a horrible state of
famine and chaos on the island of
australia until eventually they'd have
no choice but to feed on each other
the aliens intended the vast majority of
humankind to die in this brutal way
no one on earth had the ability to
resist the possibility of deterrence had
been destroyed
the human race had been herded like
animals and left to rot while the
tricelerians begin preparations to
inhabit the earth
sophon who once seemed gentle and
innocent was now a brutal and sadistic
dictator
this was the darkest period in human
history
but this wasn't the end of humanity's
story
part 3
the broadcast
as i said
during the doomsday battle several ships
got away
the crew of blue space and gravity would
become the saviors of humanity they had
detected what happened on earth and
together made the decision to fulfill
the deterrence threat revealing the
location of the two worlds
aboard their ship they possessed a
gravitational wave emitter more than
capable of completing the task
they knew that activating the universal
broadcast system would give earth one
last chance it was forced to try solaris
to leave the solar system they hoped to
buy humanity time to escape the solar
system before it was too late
315 years had passed since that morning
in the 20th century when yaowenji had
pushed another red button
the gravitational wave broadcast begin
everyone present felt a strong trimmer
the feeling seemed to come not from
without but from within each body as
though every person had become a
vibrating string
this instrument of death played for only
12 seconds before stopping
and then everything went silent
so fun was able to detect the
gravitational waves approximately one
year after they had been broadcast after
this becomes known to the tricelerians
they no longer have use for our solar
system
they simply leave
they head away from the earth the
conflict between the humans and the
tricelerians seems to be over forever
but now the existence of our world has
been revealed and a light switch had
been turned on and suddenly the earth
was visible to any hunter who happened
to be looking
the tricelerians had been powerful but
their power pales in comparison to what
awaited deeper in the dark forest
it was not known how long it would take
for humanity to be noticed
it could take decades it could take
centuries
nearly four years after the broadcast
had been activated the trisolaris star
system was annihilated
[Music]
since trisolaris had always been under
intense surveillance plenty of data was
captured concerning its extinction the
attack on the tri-solarin system was
identical to the attack on luogis 187
j3x1 a small object traveling near the
speed of light struck one of the three
stars in the system and destroyed it
through its relativistically amplified
mass
a photoid had struck one of the world's
three stars
strangely it seemed to have been
launched from some kind of spacecraft
all life on trisolaris was destroyed in
the resulting catastrophe of bright
blinding brilliance
by the time the planet emerged from the
furnace of its erupting sun
it glowed with dim red light
the entire surface of the world had been
liquefied
no one had expected this to happen so
soon and it was only a matter of time
before the earth met the same fate
the destroyed world appeared as a bright
blue star visible from earth
the destruction of the alien homeworld
brought most humans little pleasure
however
humanity grew silent
as though they were simply waiting for
something they could not name
they still had to find a way to protect
themselves
and now the matter was even more
pressing
how could a species survive long term in
such a hostile universe
even if they found the perfect world
how would they protect themselves
it turns out the secrets of the universe
go even deeper
as humanity eventually discovers
in future videos we will discuss what
becomes of humanity
now alone and exposed in the unforgiving
cosmos what will become of the solar
system and what is the destination of
the lone drifters in space who activated
the broadcast system
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
[Music]
you